johnathan now you had a prior Hollywood
career how did you get started in show
business and then what eventually led
you to your first directing job I got my
start in Hollywood working as a personal
assistant to celebrities and then
spending some time at the William Morris
Agency after which I started my own
agency called the Hollywood Madison
group which specialized in recruiting
celebrities for endorsements on behalf
of fortune 500 clients in fact I once
hired or recruited Martin Scorsese on
behalf of Philips electronics and my job
was to direct him in a spot promoting
widescreen television the launch of
widescreen TV in the US and I recall
doing a great job
basically I kept my mouth shut and I
stood in the corner but I never aspired
to be a filmmaker I never it never
occurred to me I was kind of locked in
this adolescent knee-jerk reaction to my
father where I had to go and better him
professionally and I just assumed that
would be business so I was always on the
business side of the desk and after my
father died and I started writing about
the experience and it became this movie
no one was more surprised than I well
you mention that in the film that you
had this epiphany and forgive me if I'm
skewing the facts but that you woke up
once you heard of your father's death
and realized this was not the career
that you wanted exactly and I think
that's true of a lot of people and again
I don't wish to appear gender biased but
I would think it's it's mostly a male
trait if your father doesn't love you or
doesn't show any love or acceptance and
kicks you out and tells you're worthless
a lot of people particularly guys turn
to well hell I'll go out and be bigger
than he ever was and he'll have to
respect me he'll have to love me
and so when he committed suicide and did
luck not leave a note I wasn't conscious
of these things I was you know I had the
emotional maturity of a 17 year old in
my late 30s and I just woke up one day
after he died and realized I couldn't
get out of bed and I'd lost all interest
in working as a talent agent in
Hollywood or living in Hollywood and I
didn't quite understand why until
shortly afterwards when I realized that
I was only here and I had spent my
entire adult life pursuing negative
Drive trying to prove something to
someone else and I in fact have no
interest in these things and it made me
wonder who the hell am I and what might
I have been had it not for this you know
crusade to prove my father wrong about
me and here I find myself back in
Hollywood so go figure
well you'd mentioned previously about
narcissism and I think that that's
something that drives everyone in this
town behind the camera in front of the
camera absolutely and I think it's it's
a bigger person who's able to admit that
I believe that dr. drew wrote a book
about we all are on a certain spectrum
of narcissism but seeing that you
realize your career was basically sort
of a crying out for him to notice you do
you now go back and sort of look at
similar situations in Hollywood and say
maybe this is what's driven all of us in
some sense oh absolutely and I don't
think there's a lot of mystery to it
although like you said I don't think we
we look at it as often and as clearly as
we should I think it's the oldest story
in the book that this Hollywood is a
magnet for people who
want to be famous but why because we're
all seeking acceptance we're all we're
all just children or human beings
looking for acceptance whether it's from
another human being or in some cases
millions of human beings but I was I was
no different than any other person in
this town we're all looking for most of
us are looking for acceptance and I
probably still AM
you